this morning millions of people across
the south face another dangerous morning
commute after a pre winter storm over
the weekend temperatures dropped into
the 20s overnight from Texas to Virginia
the frigid weather is turning runoff
water into hazardous black ice highway
crews are working around the clock to
keep roads safe the storm dumped up to
two feet of snow in some parts of the
southeast it's blamed for at least three
deaths many schools are closed or
opening late this morning more than 75
thousand utility customers are still
without power Meg Oliver is in a blacked
out neighborhood in Chapel Hill North
Carolina meg good morning Nora good
morning that's right crews spent the
night cutting up this massive tree that
knocked out power to this area
authorities are now worried about black
ice on the roads as the next danger
proving the effects of this storm are
far from over they seem freezing
temperatures overnight highway crews
from Georgia to Virginia this morning
are racing to keep ice off the roads I
have a major concern with every road it
doesn't matter what we get off the road
it's still gonna be wet every roads
gonna have some my North Carolina
Highway crews have spread more than
13,000 tons of salt across highways but
that hasn't stopped hundreds of vehicles
from losing control and even overturning
State Police in North Carolina and
Virginia say they've responded to nearly
two thousand crashes combined our roads
are dangerous black ice can sneak up at
a moment so please be careful if you
must be out and about
the weekends historic storm across the
southeast dropped as much snow in a day
that many areas see in a year the heavy
snowfall caused rooftops to collapse
including this one on a farm near
Charlotte killing three horses also
working through the night Power crews
who continued their push to restore
electricity to thousands of customers we
got a lot of heavy snow overnight
Allyson Clayton and her family lost
power about two days ago after a tree
crashed under the power lines outside
their home in Chapel Hill how fortunate
that that tree didn't go toward your
house we're very lucky thankfully though
we have a wood-burning fireplace we've
got a gas stove and lots of good
neighbors to help out this was that tree
it was close to 100 feet long stretching
across the road although snow storms
here are rare one of the last big ones
happened two decades ago in January when
Raleigh received up to 20 inches of snow
but this time around winter is still
officially 10 days away Gail oh joy
thank you very much meg